what is something that you've learned
from
being managed by whack and kind of
having like whack in your corner that
you are applying to your label and to
your management style
okay just
go all in with this [__] for real look
don't be afraid to be the bad guy or
look like you give a [__] just let that
[__] you know Let Her Shine for real
right it's all gonna work for her even
if
we go viral for the weirdest [__] it's
she's the woman imma look back
regardless she can slap the [__] out of
me right now
I would look bad right you gonna laugh
at me if I hit her back you gonna not
laugh at me and like be weird right
right but it's gonna go viral for her
regardless
are you guys like I was gonna say like
just in general with like the physical
[__] because it does feel like you guys
are
if from the outside looking in it feels
like an unhealthy relationship a toxic
relationship right like
um
do you think that a lot of that was
alcohol fueled like some of the [__] we
see online where you guys are like
really like scrapping you know what I'm
saying there's a lot of that alcohol
fueled or is it like
is this like some normal no sometimes it
will only be alcohol what'd you say yeah
sometimes we'd be sober
so I don't think this is do you think do
you think eventually that could be like
a situation because you know all it
takes is the wrong person to see some
somebody ends up in jail or we haven't
fought in a minute we don't do that just
work on not doing it right
just bro
that's fair I mean if we gonna keep
doing it you know
everything is is business salvageable
you know what I'm saying right
we like just like we do the business we
gotta get along and you guys have this
TV show now that's like a smash exactly
like you know so it's like
is the TV show something that you feel
like you got to turn up on when it comes
to like when the cameras are around for
entertainment purposes
I mean nah I just try to be honestly I
like to joke a lot so I'll just be funny
goofy type she
I'm sure I feel like that I feel like
I'm like that off camera but she I don't
know when the camera get on she's like
oh my gosh my jokes are not funny my
jokes are not funny on camera but off
camera
why are you joking like it's not funny
he know my reaction that's what's the
funny part like no
you gotta know your reaction obviously
you do no I really don't you surprised
me every time like she reacts different
to like
she's unpredictable